we have these fem Centric Society so if  a man doesn't know what he's doing in  life and he can't find his purpose he's  being raised by his mother and she's  like it's okay it's okay don't worry  Jordan Peterson says you know these  women in society tell men you're okay  the way you are no you're not okay the  way you are nobody is okay the way they  are yeah even women then that's a major  issue which we can get to as well why  most women are still singles because all  their babes are like yeah girl you don't  need to lose weight you're okay the way  you are no you're a boss babe nobody's  okay the way they are everybody if you  want the best you got to do better and  improve and get the best